THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE WILL CHECK IN WITH ANOTHER
DEVASTATED PART OF THE STATE
LATER IN THE HOUR.
BUT NOW.
DECLINE IS THEIR POLICY, THAT IS
THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
IT'S BEEN 20 MONTHS WITH
DEMOCRATS IN CHARGE OF CONGRESS
AND THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE THOUGHT TONIGHT WE WOULD ASK
THIS QUESTION: HOW ARE THINGS
LOOKING?
LET'S DO A QUICK INVENTORY,
SHALL WE?
FIRST, THE ECONOMY IS
COLLAPSING.
>> WE BEGIN WITH OUR TALK OF THE
TAPE AND IT'S THIS UGLY MARKETS
DOWN AGAIN TODAY AND SHORTLY
AFTER A ONE DAY REPRIEVE AND
FRESH CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT LIES
AHEAD FOR YOUR MONEY.
>> Laura: WE APPEAR TO BE
DRIFTING INTO WAR WITH RUSSIA.
>> RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN TOLD
HIS PEOPLE THAT THE U.S. IS BENT
ON DESTROYING THE RUSSIAN
HOMELAND.
ON WEDNESDAY HE DRAFTED 300,000
RESERVISTS AND THREATENED
NUCLEAR WAR.
THIS IS NOT A BLUFF, HE SAID.
>> Laura: CHINA IS THREATENING
THE UNITED STATES.
>> [SCREAMING]
[BLEEP] OBVIOUSLY THAT IS CRIME
RISING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
OUR SCHOOLS ARE FAILING FROM OUR
PEOPLE ARE BEING POISONED BY
FENTANYL.
>> THE GREATEST THREAT FACING
OUR COMMUNITIES, OUR FAMILIES,
OUR CHILDREN, IS THE CARTELS.
THE TWO CARTELS IN MEXICO THAT
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE VAST
AMOUNTS OF FENTANYL.
>> Laura: AND OUR BORDERS ARE
UNDEFENDED.
>> THIS IS A PLANNED DISASTER BY
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
>> Laura: FACED WITH ALL OF
THESE FACTS, THE BIDEN REGIME
HAS DECIDED TO FOCUS ON THREE
PRIORITIES.
FIND A WAY TO INDICT
DONALD TRUMP FOR EVERYTHING.
NUMBER 2, FIND A WAY TO BLAME
RON DeSANTIS FROM A HARM
RESULTING FROM A HURRICANE.
NUMBER 3, TRY TO GET THE MIDTERM
VOTERS TO CHOOSE MORE ABORTIONS
OVER RESTORING PROSPERITY AND
SAFETY.
NO WONDER POPULISM IS BLOOMING
EVERYWHERE.
NO WONDER MOST OF THE WATCHED
RACES THAT WERE CLOSER LEANING
DEMOCRAT JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO
ARE NOW EITHER TOSS-UPS OR
LEANING REPUBLICAN.
I WANT YOU TO LOOK AT WISCONSIN
WHERE INCUMBENT
SENATOR RON JOHNSON WHO WAS
SUPPOSEDLY IN A WEAK POSITION A
FEW WEEKS BACK IS NOW
UP 5 AGAINST MANDELA BARNES.
OR TIM MITCHELL WHO IS AN
ESSENTIALLY A DEAD HEAT WITH
INCUMBENT LIBERAL TONY EVERS AND
THE GOVERNOR'S RACE THERE.
THEN DR. OZ -- SHE'S CLOSING IN
ON MR. HOODIE WITHOUT A CLUE
JOHN FETTERMAN, HE IS ONLY DOWN
BY FOUR.
PEOPLE ARE WAKING UP, NOT JUST
TO THE WRECKAGE THAT THE
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR POLICIES
HAVE LEFT BEHIND BUT I THINK NOW
MORE OF YOU ARE STARTING TO ASK:
IS ALL OF THIS INTENTIONAL?
OR AS TEXAS AG KEN PAXTON CALLED
A PLANNED DISASTER.
EVEN BEFORE BIDEN'S
INAUGURATION, THEY BEGAN TO
FLASH THE GREEN LIGHT TO CENTRAL
AMERICANS.
WE KNEW HOW TO RESTORE THE
BORDER, HOW TO RESTORE ORDER
THERE AND CLOSE IT DOWN BECAUSE
TRUMP DID IT, BUT BIDEN DID THE
OPPOSITE.
HE DITCHED THE REMADE IN MEXICO
POLICY AND PUT KAMALA HARRIS IN
CHARGE -- IS THERE EVER A SIGN
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE NEVER
INTENDED TO ENFORCE OUR BORDER,
THAT WAS IT.
ANOTHER CLUE THIS WAS
INTENTIONAL, BIDEN AND HIS CREW
HAVE MADE IT ABUNDANTLY CLEAR
THEY THINK AMERICA HAS A
TERRIBLE PAST THAT INFORMS OUR
PRESENT.
>> RACISM GETS REFLECTED IN
DISCRIMINATION IN HOUSING AND
EMPLOYMENT AND THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
>> RACISM IS REAL IN AMERICA TWO
AND IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN.
XENOPHOBIA IS REAL IN AMERICA,
AND ALWAYS HAS BEEN.
SEXISM TOO.
>> THE ORIGINAL SIN OF SLAVERY
TWO BELIEVED WHITE SUPREMACY
INTO OUR FOUNDING DOCUMENTS AND
PRINCIPLES.
>> Laura: IF AMERICA IS TRULY
SYSTEMICALLY RACIST, AFTER BROWN
VERSUS BOARD OF EDUCATION AFTER
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT, AFTER
THE ELECTION OF THE FIRST BLACK
PRESIDENT, TWO TIMES -- HOW CAN
THIS SYSTEM THAT IS THAT CORRUPT
AFTER ALL OF THAT BE SAVED AT
ALL?
THE ANSWER FROM THE LEFT IS IT
CAN'T BE SAVED.
THEY HATE OUR CONSTITUTION, THEY
HATE OUR JUDEO-CHRISTIAN
TRADITION, THEY HATE CAPITALISM,
AND THEY NOW BELIEVE IT NEEDS TO
BE RESET, COURTESY OF
GEORGE SOROS.
THE RESET WHICH THEY HAVE
DISCUSSED AND NAUSEA HIM ON
COLLEGE CHAMPIONS AND THAT DAVOS
REQUIRES A COMPLETE REORDERING
OF ALL OF SOCIETY BUT ESPECIALLY
AMERICAN SOCIETY.
THAT MEANS THINGS LIKE NO MORE
EMPLOYMENT, NO MORE JOBS BASED
ON OBJECTIVE CRITERIA OR MERIT.
>> IN THE 232 YEAR HISTORY OF
THE U.S., HOLD THAT POSITION.
>> SHE'S MAKING HISTORY, THE
FIRST BLACK WOMAN.
>> THE FIRST OPENLY TRANS
ASSISTANT SECRETARY FOR HEALTH.
>> Laura: YOU GET THE POINT,
THE CABINET, THE TOP STAFF, THEY
ARE PRESIDING OVER ONE NIGHTMARE
AFTER ANOTHER.
THEY OFFER NO SOLUTIONS, ONLY
ACTIONS THAT MAKE MATTERS WORSE
BUT THEY ARE FIRST SO WE SHOULD
FORGET ABOUT THE FAILURES.
ADMINISTRATION FOCUSED ON TRULY
SERVE IN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
TRULY SERVING THEIR STANDARD OF
LIVING AND SAFETY THEY WOULD
HAVE CANNED JANET YELLEN AT
TREASURY, ALEJANDRA MALLORCA MY
ARCUS, GRAHAM AT ENERGY,
PETE BUTTIGIEG TRANSPORTATION,
THEY WOULD'VE IT FIRED MONTHS
AGO.
IT LEADS US TO THE ONLY SENSIBLE
CONCLUSION.
THEIR GOAL IS OUR DECLINE.
INFLATION THAT JANET YELLEN
IGNORED HAS THE MARKETS DOWN TO
ITS LOWEST POINT SINCE
NOVEMBER 2020.
>> I BELIEVE THERE IS A PATH
THROUGH THIS THAT CAN SUCCEED IN
BRINGING DOWN INFLATION WHILE
ALSO MAINTAINING WHAT I THINK
ALL OF US WOULD REGARD AS A
STRONG LABOR MARKET.
>> Laura: HOW WAS SHE EVEN
EMPLOYED?
THE SUPPLY CHAIN THAT MAYOR PETE
WAS SUPPOSED TO ADDRESS?
IT'S STILL MESSED UP.
>> OVER $1.5 BILLION ARE GOING
INTO AWARDS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
ANNOUNCED TODAY TO BUILD THAT
WORLD LEADING TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM.
STRENGTH AND SUPPLY CHAINS,
CREATE JOBS, ADVANCE EQUITY AND
IMPROVE ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY.
>> Laura: CHINA IS ON THE MOVE
IN SOUTH AND CENTRAL AMERICA.
EVEN FUNDING RUSSIA'S WAR IN
UKRAINE.
JOHN KERRY, THE CLIMATE CZAR IS
LEFT BEGGING CHINA TO KEEP
FOCUSING ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> WHAT CAN BE DONE ABOUT CHINA?
THERE IS RELUCTANCE TO
PARTICIPATE IN AFFAIRS OF
CLIMATE CONTROL THAT OTHER
NATIONS --
>> INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH, CHINA
HAS A PLAN.
MORE ELECTRIC VEHICLES, THEN ALL
THE REST THE WORLD PUT TOGETHER.
>> YOU GET THE DRIFT HERE.
AMERICA IS HUMILIATED, THAT CLIP
FROM JOHN KERRY IS AN EXAMPLE OF
OUR HUMILIATION.
THEY WANT AS MANY WARDS OF THE
STATE AS THEY CAN FROM AS MANY
PEOPLE DEPENDENT ON THE
GOVERNMENT AS THEY CAN.
WHAT YOU THINK LEFT-WING
GOVERNORS TO OPEN DURING COVERT
WHEN IT WAS OBVIOUS THEY COULD
TO.
THEY CARE MORE ABOUT FAMILIES
AND YOUNG PEOPLE?
PLEASE PICK OUT THEY DIDN'T CARE
ABOUT THE FAMILIES AND THE YOUNG
PEOPLE.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT SETTING THE
STAGE FOR THE NEW NORMAL.
A NEW NORMAL WHERE YOU WOULD
HAVE LESS FREEDOM, LESS TRAVEL,
LOWER STANDARD OF LIVING.
WOULD GLOBAL ELITES ARE IN POWER
THEY WILL ALWAYS FIND AN EXCUSE
TO TAKE AWAY YOUR FREEDOM.
UNDER BUSH, IT WAS 9/11 AND THE
PATRIOT ACT.
OF COURSE THE PANDEMIC, LOCKDOWN
AND BIG TECH CENSORSHIP.
THAN IT WAS JANUARY 6TH AT DOJ'S
DOMESTIC TERROR FOCUS.
THEY WILL BAN GAS POWERED CARS,
AND BECAUSE ENERGY PRICES TO
SKYROCKET.
TO THEM, WE ARE THE REAL THREAT
AND THEY FEEL THEY NEED TO READ
STRAIN US.
THE ITALIAN PRIME MINISTER'S
WARNING FOR CITIZENS NOT TO FALL
FOR THIS DOMINATION PLAY OF THE
LEFT.
SHE WANTS ITALIAN SCHOOLS TO
TEACH NOT TO TURN STUDENTS
AGAINST THEIR PARENTS OR THEIR
CULTURE.
WHAT REALLY UNNERVES THEM IS SHE
ACTUALLY QUOTES GK CHESTERTON.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
>> Laura: SHE'S FEARLESS,
SHE'S FORTHRIGHT, AND SHE'S
WELL-SPOKEN.
A TRIPLE THREAT.
LIKE HER, WE ALMOST REFUSE TO
LIVE IN THE LEFT LIBERAL
DICTATORSHIP OF IDEAS.
WE HAVE TO REALIZE, NONE OF WHAT
WE ARE SEEING HAPPEN AROUND YOU,
THE BAD STUFF IS HAPPENING BY
ACCIDENT.
THE LEFT IS BUSY, THEY GOT BUSY
CREATING THE AMERICA THAT THEY
WANT, ONE THAT IS RUN BY A SMALL
SLIVER OF RICH PEOPLE WHO FLOAT
ABOVE IT ALL, THEN POOR PEOPLE
WHO DEPEND ON GOVERNMENT
SERVICES.
AND JUST A TINY MIDDLE-CLASS WHO
NEVER REALLY GET AHEAD.
THIS ELECTION COMING UP IS OUR
CHANCE TO SAY NO TO THESE
DEVIOUS PLANS